okay
okay what up guys welcome to the just
pearly things youtube channel your girl
pearl is behind the camera today
because oh no oh no that was me guys
that was my fault um
because because today we have a live
first date on the show
[Music]
um as you guys know we try to find love
on the pre-game between guests
and these two guests just really hit it
off right guys
yeah i guess so i guess so yeah
so today um they're gonna get a
three-course meal live um let us know
okay and i'm gonna ask them questions
behind the camera
um and so let us know in the chat how
you think the date is going and any
questions you guys want me to ask them
oh we just got a new subscriber
welcome welcome to the family welcome to
the channel oh wait okay let me hold on
guys let me go get their first meal
the first meal
what you got for us what have we got we
got cheese we've got cheese
want to drink oh i'll take some water
yes
i have no idea what that but after food
i don't have no idea what type of cheese
that is it's philadelphia i think like
cream cheese
with plastic cups no worries man it's
all good though
oh thanks this is so romantic
right
i'm gonna i'm trying to live off the
cheese
okay guys
what made you want to do this live date
and hang out with each other
interesting question you can go fast nah
you can definitely go nah i mean um i
mean for from the podcast that we did
last time we're kind of like good energy
good vibes we thought why not come on
do this like as a date
yeah i think i'd agree with that i think
yeah good energy good vibes i think i
think we had a connection actually a
little bit a little bit
what is the most attractive thing about
each other
i'd probably say her eyes
i kind of like you like as a whole like
in general
that's a big that's a big hole and he
did say he could build a house that's
another like isn't the house thing
attractive it's so attractive can we
talk about men that work trade jobs like
oh he fixed my cabinet today
i fully did it
so yeah
okay
um so if you guys
were to date
who would cook in the relationship
that's
i'd say i don't mind cooking because
i've done it for so long now i cook at
home for my mom and stuff
but
yes i don't mind cooking you know oh
i guess it depends like
who can cook like who's at home the most
i think it makes more sense yeah but i
don't mind i like to cook as well
the dog is loose
dog's out of here what's wrong with that
no idea was she sick or something
i will check technical difficulties guys
okay
sorry my dog was being crazy
okay
um
do you guys like to read yeah
no
um what about audiobooks i have audio
but yeah i was going to say ever since
the invention of wood or audible um yeah
i'd say just listen to them on on the
audiobook app audible app story i don't
really like to read like physical books
physical books not really
actually not not at all unless i
absolutely have to which is like for
university work or something like that
other than that not really
i don't know i really do like to read
like i feel like i kind of like
went out of reading like i didn't really
get into it because i couldn't find a
good book like but when you do find a
good book i do find that it's like
really easy to read like you don't
really have to like oh let me pick up
this book like for uni like you kind of
have to read the book so probably why
it's not as enjoyable but if you find a
good book then it's like kind of easy
and fun fair enough yeah
um i got a compliment on the 7-eleven
shirt oh oh yeah
i appreciate it thank you
um
what do you guys what do you guys like
oh no
sorry totally cool okay what are you
guys looking for like do you guys you're
trying to get married you're trying to
date around like what's your end goal
well end goal is like obviously like
something committed
that's gonna go somewhere for the end
goal
well personally for me it's obviously
like um i like i said in the podcast
before this obviously
eight years probably like i'd like to be
like married or you know have a look
yeah but more or less the same because
obviously right now i'm still you know
learning i'm still in education
i'm working part-time but you know just
i'd like to have that goal in about
eight years eight nine years i'd say i
kind of relate to you on that no like i
do feel like right now i'm still quite
young to
like
go straight into like a really committed
relationship that's probably gonna like
i don't know like lead to marriage like
quite early i feel like yeah it's
something that's for the future like
maybe in five or seven years there's
obviously like we might have like a body
clock it's also something to think about
and especially if you want to have
children as well i kind of gotta factor
in that in the whole
long-term relationships time cycle yeah
if you guys could have anyone at dinner
who would it be
like any dinner guest
but that door alive
what dead or like better live yeah oh uh
i really don't know
i'll probably say michael jackson i'm
not gonna lie to you
okay why
i don't know it's just like when i was a
kid i admired him as a as a songwriter
as a dancer i i loved the moonwalk i
used to i did a talent show when i
danced to one of these songs so you know
it's uh yeah probably i'd probably say
him i'm not gonna lie like as a kid i
was really scared of michael jackson
like if you show me a picture of michael
jackson i get so freaked out i'm me too
i relate yeah like i said what do you do
yeah
what for everyone everyone that's the
same what about you
i really don't know like no one comes
like to mine immediately so i really
don't know fair enough i can't argue
with that maybe jesus
you know who i would do i would do
amelia earhart because i want to know
what happened to her yeah i just want to
know she died well i know but like but
how
i know
i thought it was no but some people
think she like disappeared like she was
like taken or something maybe she's like
i don't want to live in a me like a
world that's all like no women's right
so i'm just gonna scoot over to like a
private island i just think nobody knows
yeah no one else
um what is the worst first date or
second date you've ever been on
college i don't oh
i don't remember you know i'm not gonna
lie to you i don't i don't nothing comes
to me no yeah no no no no that doesn't
come to mind about like i've never had
like a really like bad date experience
to be honest which is like there's
nothing really comes to mind in that
section to be honest
no i like nothing comes to mind either
like for a really like bad day
like probably like more like pet peeves
like i know it's something that's
annoying but like nothing like it's not
bad
um
try the cheese and let me know if you
like it sorry what try the cheese cheese
i'm trying to lay off about
it's a three-course
she meal us to eat yeah she wants us to
eat i have a knife
make it easier for you yeah
do you like cheese
yeah
i love cheeseburger i got it from the
co-op so
it's one of those cheeses where i feel
like it would taste better when it's
warm
because like i like you know melted oh
really yeah like i liked my is it
supposed to be warm i thought it wasn't
no no like a lot of the cheeses
obviously when you have like eating
burgers you have them like the those
squared fake cheeses but they melted
that i prefer cheese like on something
yeah like it's got i prefer hot like
melted on like with like you know like
ham and cheese it's warm warm
i love cheese i think it's just like my
mom's french like pretty much growing up
was just cheese
all the time what's your what is your
background by the way like
like all the
all this stuff
so my
like my dad's side is like jamaican
but they were all born in the uk so like
they're british and my mother's side is
french fair enough i'm just um a stone
called lithuanian no
nothing in that i actually know actually
my
i do believe my my my dad's names
is ukrainian so i'm not too sure how
much percent of my ukrainian but yeah i
live way near
all my life pretty much what's the
history of like lithuania like did the
borders change like a lot like could it
could it be possible that it is
ukrainian
or that i wouldn't be able to tell you
to be honest i don't know myself i don't
really look into them type of things
okay
this cheese is good that's not bad i
tried to stay off it though
so you could say this restaurant it's
like top tier come on five stars five
stars
i'll recommend joint trip advisor
um
would you be bothered if um your
girlfriend didn't work like would you
are you like the provider type
are you like you got to work i mean
i
hmm
i mean it wouldn't be like a real like a
sign that
that would be out the question like
obviously i don't mind like working and
stuff obviously it'd obviously be better
for the both of us if like we both
worked and we had our own income i had
our own money you know i mean so i
wouldn't say that would be the worst
thing but
how do you feel about that
i don't know like it depends like what
phase of the relationship you're in like
imagine if like we're dating right now
i'm like i'm going to quit my job
because i'm dating dobby does
i think that would be a bit weird yeah
that would be appealing
yeah to be honest the only good example
that i can give of um
a pers like a person actually moved a
bit too fast and actually worked out for
them is actually my best friend
um here he had found a girl in
university and then they
they eat for like i don't know i think
it was like
maybe three months before and now
they're living together they ain't even
been together for like under a year and
they're living together like in their
own house and stuff so you know good on
them shout out to my boy lucas
living that good life yeah man
hands down
name three things you guys have in
common
oh
you think you have in common oh
well
we both agree that
apparently if you can build a house
that's sexy
yeah that's fine i think we're both
quite sporty yeah
yeah i'm sporty very much so yes i'm
very active
and
how are you with like education and
stuff because i don't really
know how did you get your name really my
type of 14. i think i am quite academic
really yeah yeah
um i do well i i i i don't sound like
i'm i'm flunking but like i do the
this year i've been doing better but
like mostly i just be trying to like do
the best to get you know just to get the
grades yeah but it's not for everyone i
don't think like
being academic is a sign of like you're
more intelligent than anybody else i
don't feel like like universities like
obviously i go through high school i
feel like stay in high school you know
do that but university is really
optionally like if it's not if it's not
for you generally not for you i i chose
it because um mama had a pretty much a
knife to my throat
joke joke you know what i'm saying
before anyone starts calling 999 in the
uk
life
nah man
i'm i'm over time i'm over the age of
i'm not i'm not a minor anymore i can't
do that and plus even if i did well my
mom would probably just give me the
phone me like call him tell them yeah
tell them like
you'll be here in 20 minutes and she'll
look at me
that means i've got 90 minutes to beat
us like
she's like my mom
so okay so sporty and
what was the first one we both think
building a house is sexy oh we both like
to cook yeah i love it i love you i like
that to cook so we've got some there's
no things in common last three
hopefully by the end of the video some
more
okay share a personal problem that
you're going through right now and ask
your the part your partner's advice on
how to fix it
a personal personal problem um
interesting
i don't know
i mean okay cool um
i'm in debt to my friend
mm-hmm
about 2 000 pounds that's that's not
really a big issue no no because
obviously you know i'm it's not really a
big issue and he said don't worry about
it but like i'm the type of person like
if i borrow something i really really
want to
like as soon as i like i don't like
owing people i don't like being in debt
or nothing like that so it's yeah it's
always in the back of my mind like
eating meat slowly yeah yeah maybe you
should like um
like i've been in debt to someone before
and i think the best way to do it is
probably like discuss with them like how
long it's gonna take you to pay them
back and but okay like maybe
over a year i'm gonna pay you every
month this amounts and it's clear to
them that you're making an effort like
they're getting paid they see the money
coming like consistency consistently but
you don't have the need to pay them like
two grand obviously because that's a lot
of money
like in one go so if i just like oh
let's make like a plan how i'm gonna pay
you that doesn't mean
that you're thinking about it all the
time so you just pay what you can each
month and then they'll be happy that
you're paying and they'll be happy that
you're acknowledging it as well and then
you won't be like oh like i've got to do
this and this and you won't feel like
you won't need to buy things for
yourself at the same time if you're
saying like oh i'm going to pay you like
50 pound a month for the next like i
don't know how many years then you can
still pay for your own stuff and still
buy things that you want to do so like
if you go on holidays like oh why is
this guy on holiday when he owes me
money that kind of thing
fair enough so yeah
what about you i don't know i'm trying
to think of like a problem that i have
i don't
okay my personal i'm not really good at
giving advice so just make it easy on me
okay my personal problem is to um should
i move out and live um
out of uni accommodation
when it's nicer or should i just save my
money i'm actually the perfect person to
answer this question save my money and
stay on campus
i'll put it to you this way
i've been in university last year and i
lived off campus from the first year
and then when i came back here i'm still
off campus now the big those are the two
biggest mistakes that i've done purely
for the fact that
when you live on campus you meet a lot
of new people that you're just gonna
influence your life in a big way right
obviously you're on campus so there's a
lot of benefits to being on campus
because obviously you have the 24-hour
library over here for us so for us
anyways i don't know if you every
university has it um you obviously have
um
everything yeah yeah and then whereas
like and you obviously know the phone
about like all the parties are going
down and stuff like that so you get to
meet people and you know and make new
friends and relationships and whatever
whereas for the way i've done it i just
live i lived off campus and i missed out
on the whole lot so i'd say i'd say for
like going forward i'd say just stay on
campus for the full full university
experience because that's i'm going to
be on campus by next year
i think that's good advice because i do
like like i've enjoyed campus so far the
only reason is like to move out is
probably to be like i also have friends
in london they're like oh let's move in
together and it's kind of like oh do i
choose to live with my friends or do i
choose to
stay where it's comfortable yeah yeah
enough well yeah maybe i'll stay on
campus
okay would you guys like to take a shot
yeah
so like i wouldn't make up the questions
like you can make them up please make up
the questions okay i can't i can't i
i think vodka would be better for me but
okay no worries no worries i'll do shots
no worries i haven't done the bucket
shots in a while so
yeah i'm not really a fan of whiskey i
tried it i was like whoa
now we're gonna find out who's the real
alcoholic in this
who doesn't flinch and i'll i'll do the
next course yeah
right
so what's a really good mixer with vodka
is like ginger like ginger beer or like
ginger ale for the americans out there
like i think it's a really good mixer
like you won't taste well the vodka if
that's what you want if that's your
desire
sponsored by club
right
did we shot it now
i don't know do you want to ask a
question first do you want to do you
want to do the truth
i don't know like pearl do we need your
input are we doing this by ourselves
i'm preparing the next okay she's
cooking she's cooking
okay okay
i feel like we should shot first you
know what yeah let's show first but wait
wait wait isn't that it's like truth or
shock yeah so you ask a question and if
you don't want to answer it for some
assuming
okay
okay so what do you think of the
question oh yeah but that's that's a bit
yeah that's that's where i was like okay
should we just do a shot first then
we'll go see what's on there yeah like
maybe like a half shot like drink a bit
i don't i don't drink a bad shot yet
okay sure okay then shot
that was nasty
exactly i don't drink vodka
my preferred drink of choice is a rum
it's wrong this guy's a yachty
to be more specific
um kraken or ray nephews right nephews
the devil's drink the devil's june or
rays of sunshine
why
why would you do this to me
so what we got here uh jameson is a very
nice whiskey so it's cheap buddies and
that's the right tasting i don't know if
i like whiskey like have you tried it
before yeah i've tried it and every
experience i've been like
i have to acquire that taste to like it
i think i've had this with coke before
yeah
yeah
all right
we asked some questions asking questions
would you want to refill with the thing
if you want to answer i think i'll try
this yeah all right
also started by captain morgan
have you thought of any questions no is
there anything you want to know about me
being put on a spot like this is you
know doing it live like you know i feel
like we like if it was off camera and
we've done it like that i think it'll be
right more actually the fighter you're
gonna put on the spot is a bit you know
yeah like i forget the camera's here
like i'm like it's there but then like
yeah i forget about it
[Music]
i guess wow so that's sort of simple
how's your um how's your family like
relationship like how are you good with
your family are you close yeah i
wouldn't say like
i'm as close with my family as i want to
be like i'd love to be like really close
with my sister like i see other people
i'm like oh like i tell my sister
everything i'll tell my brother
everything i kind of wish i had that but
i have so much love for my siblings and
we will have all like good relationships
like close contact but as you know like
i have a really big family i have a lot
of siblings so i think because of that
i'm not like are you the favorite
of course i'm the favorite like how
could it not be
all passwords are like tiana two three
four
fair enough anything anything you wanna
know about me that
how's your family live then um
well uh my whole family is all good to
be honest it's very good actually um but
my mom you know your mom's just like up
and down up and down you know sometimes
she yells at me for no reason but that's
what moms do but i feel like like moms
have a sixth sense because like if
they're in the house and they're
downstairs doing nothing but you're
upstairs doing nothing they'll always
find like out of nowhere something that
you need to do something that you need
to do
so annoying today should be like tiana
like to come up like should call me from
downstairs like can you make me a tea
like you're closer to the kitchen than
me like
oh actually one second let me i'm gonna
yep one second
because i i did
uh i'm gonna pretty cool oh
oh mac and cheese health and cook
pelican come on chefs
i was going to bring up the i was going
to bring up the um the questions that i
asked you before
should i should i do it yeah do it all
right cool for sure though yeah
um
one second
right
it's like the basic this is like a
little bit of a naughty version
so
it is going to be a bit of the r bit
spicy right so this one is going to be
well sort of simple simple we'll start
off with some flirty questions and you
can ask me and then we'll go from there
um
yeah yeah
okay yeah actually you want to read some
of them out actually so we don't know so
we can be caught off by surprise i think
i need a shot ready for yeah yeah it's
right it's ready it's ready it's ready i
feel like you have more shot than i do
i mean you want no you want a bigger
shot i could bore you maybe a little bit
okay
my kind of woman you know i got work
tomorrow i better relax
is that better but now we're not
matching
that now you've got like yeah we'll call
it we're not
good we're good twice the size of
yourself
right okay we're ready for the questions
all right i'm going to do it on the
count of three you point
okay on the count of three oh yeah oh
actually oh this is
who do you think would be better in bet
okay like
change to
yeah yeah or drink if you don't want to
answer it i think i would be like i
don't know like how you would know that
because it's like yeah that's that's
that's that's a bit of a controversial
okay because like i'm like a humble five
like i said i i said it off camera i'm
like a humble father i'm not overly
crazy but not you know so dull that's
kind of boring you know i mean
so
i'm gonna give you know i'm a point i'm
points to her just because
you know i'll be
yeah i'll answer that one i'll answer
that one i respect it
take your time no rush
i love the way there's like no mixer
it's just pure alcohol on the table
oh i can get you one that's fine
we're doing shots very hospitable
go ahead
what's the um what's the next question
okay
do either of you still talk to your exes
yes
yes
um
do either of you still have feelings for
your exes no
let the world let the wounded go like
let's move on it's that that part of my
life is obvious i'm moving on to
better better things
okay i'm gonna read super chats real
quick guys can you hear my dog
because i i'm hoping that the mics
aren't picking it up very sorry if they
are
she can be annoying sometimes okay ten
dollars
from mgtow by logic have a pint on me
thank you
um also let me know in the chat if you
guys like these because this could be
like a weekly thing i do with people
that have been on the show
um 20 20. that being said if i see her
with another man i am going to lose it
look at players got to play
[Laughter]
what if what if it's you with another
woman
that will happen
i'm not going to type a guy
okay um
20 for new mics and 10 for the rum fund
thank you ninja watcher for life for the
rum fund i like that rum fun okay
i'm taking seriously uh come on okay
would you delete your social media if
your partner asked you to
mm-hmm
and depends on the intention yeah like
if it works like mi6 and okay i get it
but like
you did you don't
they're just one question
i don't understand like you need to have
a good reason
because i have a lot of international
friends that's probably the main way i
keep in contact with well
social media is how people with all my
family like facebook all that's
instagram a lot of my family are on like
the mainstream um socials so i'd
probably just keep it there for family
reasons yeah i feel like most of the
time it's like maybe a jealousy thing
that people would ask someone to delete
like a special and the funny thing is
it's not like that i talk to like a lot
of like girls or just people in general
just like well like if someone asked me
yeah yeah yeah and it's just one of
those things where
if someone asks me like oh you show me a
phone i'll show you my phone i don't
care like oh you can go through that but
you've got to understand right in in
order in society like i'm like a man is
allowed to have female friends like i am
going to talk to other girls not it
would never be in any type of other ways
just
it's just having a conversation you know
i mean like yeah you know yeah i think
people have to understand that you have
people in your life before you come
there so when you're dating someone
there's already people that exist in
that person's life that they've known
that person longer than you you have to
respect that so i can have a friend
that's like
you know 10 years old like i've known
for 10 years and like someone i could
date needs to respect that i've known
this person a lot longer than i'm dating
yeah fair enough
go on give us give us a shot give us a
shot question okay um
[Music]
have you ever tried to picture the other
person naked
no just now
go on give us a harder one man that's
that's that's like
what kind of question is that like if a
girl is attracted of course
so every girl that you find attractive
you picture naked absolutely i feel like
every guy does
at some point yeah
um
[Music]
but i was
like not that funny
what's your favorite position
i don't know i think they all have their
value
i don't know what i want to say you know
i thought you would say doggy style
man that's the most the most common it's
obviously it's like it has to be there
but it's not my favorite now my favorite
probably
no i'm not gonna see her i'm gonna
keep it a mystery
maybe i'll find out
um at what at what age did you guys lose
at what
i have to
here do you want me to get you a chaser
no i'm alright are you sure it's shut
for sure you can't have no chaser that's
no point okay okay
um okay
at what age did you guys lose your
virginity
oh i actually as a guy actually quite
lost it quite late to be honest i think
i'm 17. oh yeah i was really yeah i was
i was 18 so you beat me today
but like a month till 18 so i've been
quite late in comparison to my friends
i've done it just after like a week
after my birthday i did like probably
like a week before my birthday
fair enough i feel like that's kind of
was it like a like a birthday sex or was
it no
no no i didn't know the person i really
know
oh
rate each other one to ten
i think you're an eight
wait do you want me to use my my scales
or
whatever you would wait or wanted to
because my because my skills are a
little bit different like no i i go
from one to five look wise and then
everything apart above that is like it's
more like to do with like you know like
what type of like aspects do you bring
to you know are you carrying all that
stuff you know so i'd say
i'd say like a solid like 8.5 oh
so about about how many dates would you
have to go on for him to get it
yeah how
[Laughter]
many minutes getting hot in here
great service great service thank you
the service is so great here like highly
recommend like
come on the show stop by thank you
i think maybe three
like three good days three good days
three good dates it's probably you know
because you know you know you say three
days but it's actually like um i saw it
and i don't know if it's actually true i
only saw it and i think it was
i think it was a helmet your mother the
tv show apparently it's like
three days is like the normal
for people to have sex like it was like
you go through three days on the third
day you have sex that thing i don't know
if it's true so don't quote me on that
chat if you know
let us know down in the comments if
that's correct or if it's not
yeah i feel like three days like you've
already like on the second day you
already know that you like this person
you're attracted to this person and
probably on the third date you've
established like an emotional connection
but
for any other reason that you'd want to
wait longer it's probably like some
ulterior motive like maybe you want to
wait till marriage or like you want to
do something else
but i do feel like
average is probably three yeah
what is the craziest place that you guys
have had sex oh i knew this was coming
guys put super chats and then i will ask
them the questions that you put in the
chat
i just don't feel like this is like a
camera appropriate question yeah i'm not
going to answer that
why don't you drink it you know you
already answered the question
you already answered the question
alcoholic
everybody loves a drink
every now and again every night i didn't
know i would like that actually yeah i
prefer to because i prefer dark rum that
cracker is probably my favorite because
it's like a
like a dark but sweet one i've never
tried kraken
what's on the list
it's on the list but you know
are you guys snugglers you guys touchy
people
yeah yeah that's i'm very much so yeah
are they my love language are you like
are you a big spoon or a little spoon
type of person i can switch it up yeah
but thank you
jesus thank you because i'm gonna oh i'm
an impossible every now and again i know
a guy likes to be the small spoon yeah
no past relationships has always been
like oh you know can you like you know i
was always the biggest i mean you know
but a good question i want to ask like
how how come guys arms don't get like
tired oh
this no no no no no no no i have my bros
my bros my bro
this is this is no no listen um
i'm probably gonna bait out every single
guy
in the world
ma like oh like you don't understand
like we do that
for your comfort so we are like
like we are struggling like you don't
understand like when you you know when
you leave listen when you leave the room
to go to the toilet bay like you know hi
it's sorry it's like morning babe like
you know and you walk in like all arm is
like i knew it like we are literally
giving my arm cprs for the second round
because when you want to come back
you're going to want to be the you know
yeah like i tried being the big spoon i
was like wait so you feel like this all
the time yeah yeah like where i'm
supposed to go is it like a cheat code
i mean okay so the perfect the perfect
spot for me right is if like if we're
snuggling
a little bit no no i'm saying like if
your face if you're turned away from me
and i have my arm over you like this but
i'm trying to go have you like right
like body body type thing it's it's
under the pillow right but just by the
neck part because it's like you dip into
it and it's just so much more
comfortable for the girl okay chicos
guys
i didn't know but i kind of like i was
like that must you must feel of course
absolutely
okay good to know
how does a woman let a guy know she
likes him and vice versa
i guess there's a question for me then
it's for both of us no i said in vice
versa besides um
i'm a strong well now i was about
strongly um
it's
i feel like it's like if we show like
the way we show it's more like we give
you that that time of day because like
in the in we're in a situation where
we're both busy people we both have our
own lives and someone to like if you're
meeting another person you're now taking
your out your time out your busy
schedule to go and you know do things
with her but if you like her or you you
want to be with her no matter how busy
you are you will make that time for that
person no matter how you know how you
get so that's how i think that's how men
really show it like we go
whatever it is it's a yes for us like oh
you want to you want to go to the park
yes you want to go walk my dog yes you
want to go to the shop with me yes you
know it's just like we give you that
yeah like you just we wanna we make you
the priority type thing okay
i think maybe with women it's a bit more
subtle because i know it's like a face
or floor for women like we do like
really subtle things like maybe eye
contact i don't know maybe post
something or like i don't know but i
feel like
personally i feel like i'm quite direct
like oh like let's go on another day
let's do this let's do that and then i
feel like you would know
like it's subtle but like you would like
as a as a guy
we've discussed this like in the past
past course we us guys we we are capable
of many things we're great creatures but
we just one thing one thing and that's
not as strong our strong suit is picking
up on like these little girly hints yeah
but like eye contact is quite strong so
if i start making eye contact you're
gonna be like okay like what does she
mean by that yeah no of course i would
question him but like uh i have to know
to be honest like i always keep eye
contact that's for me as a from men's
point of view if you're looking at
someone's eyes when you're talking to
them that actually shows the sign of
respect like i'm not lying to you i'm
looking dead in the street
so it's like it is kind of it is but it
isn't what you know i mean so i agree
and but disagree with you what you said
yeah i feel like women need well
personally i need to adopt being a bit
more direct like i am like i lived in
germany for so long but i'm still like
oh yeah like i'll say like oh it's going
under the day but i won't be like direct
about my feelings
fair enough
what is a rule each of you have that's a
big no-no
in a relationship
please don't be crazy
please lord lord watch over me
now um
you want to take this one after first
i don't know
a big rule it doesn't come something
doesn't come to mind are we talking like
when you say no no i mean like like a
big red flag that would just be like
like you would stop talking to someone
or dump them over this like or have a
really serious conversation with them oh
um
cheating yeah
definitely one of them that's like the
best but if you notice it's it's one of
those things where it's like it's a very
very
common answer for most people like oh
that's a deal breaker you like but
that's with everything like if you cheat
then it's like
everyone would say like obviously he's
cheating because it's like it's it's you
don't do that someone cheated on you
would you break up absolutely sounds
done okay yeah that's good
what do you guys define as cheating
i think sleeping with somebody else like
a sexual act with somebody else that's
what you classify as cheating yeah oh
you ladies you have it easy then
now me purchasing someone they're like
i'm talking like yeah someone can kiss
you like look it's gonna be hard to
define i'd look i i give my true love
when when i get into a relationship i
give my trust right until that choice is
broken i try a person's trust to regain
a person's trust that's like near to
impossible for some people right
um so
i don't know if i'm with you i'm i trust
you and until you know like until proven
otherwise so if i if i you know if you
want to go out with the girls you go out
with the girls you wanna you wanna shake
your ass at the club go shake your eyes
at the club but like
just don't you you know i mean like
don't involve another guy into this or
like you know i mean or at least they
have the courage you should be like like
tell the guys like no like you know i
mean i've got a mans up thing that's
that's that's the red flag cause
obviously i don't care if you want to
fly well you know you want to be
flirtatious for like a little fridge
like even then like i'll be like iffy
but like i'll i'll give that up dancing
with another guy oh uh is that like
jamaican so you know what that looks
like
oh i've been to the nottingham carnival
carnival for example i've been to the
hill
[Music]
that's a bit of a red flag for me
because like then i have to go and then
i have to be like the man of territory
and be like get the [ __ ] off my girl i
think it's a bit disrespectful like if
you've got a man then like yeah because
obviously
you know the way i describe it look if i
don't know about it just don't
god forbid you let me lending me finding
out right so
i would if i was there as a man officer
because obviously men are as funny as we
saw we are men of territory right so if
we have a female and we see that female
dancing with another man obviously it's
not the first thing that's not going to
come like what are you doing is going to
be it's going to be like this no no no
no no it's not going to be that it's
going to be
i'm not going to say anything to you i'm
gonna have to go now deal with this guy
telling him that this is my girl and you
need to yeah probably have a fight with
him and then then and only then i will
come to you and i will tell you my peace
of mind you know what i mean yeah you
know i mean but that's that's the way we
are i've worked in a relationship i
don't know why people would like why
would you put your partner in that kind
of situation where they'd have to go for
all of that like like i wouldn't do an
accident
but i feel like the ultimate cheating
act is probably like
probably sexual intercourse or anything
sexual of nature it's probably like
cheating yeah
but yeah unless they're like an actor
then what can you do fair enough
oh
thank you for the super chat
frank keep up the austin awesome work hp
thank you appreciate it again guys if
you have specific questions for the date
super chat them and i will ask within
reason we've been reading with
everything everything
um okay
what is you guys's ultimate celebrity
crush
well i have so many
i'm sorry ariana grande
really
on concert oh my god i've been to the
vip i met the other one when she was in
the ot
she's a beautiful woman she's a very i
yeah i'd say ariana grande before i run
around i don't think i had anyone like
unless like when we were kids like you
know when you used to watch like like
not cartoons but like those um kids tv
shows type thing i'd i'd like
nickelodeon
yeah but even no no no just a bit
definitely not i don't think i've had
anyone apart from around the ground to
be honest
yeah i mean i have so many like i don't
know who i would choose right now like i
need to think about it just give me like
your top three just
you know
okay it's like cillian murphy
idris alba
tom hardy i don't know i think there's
more but like those are the first that
come to mind
really yeah
okay
do you think so
um
i think accent plays such an important
role in how attractive someone is i
think that's like what's or something
for all three of them i've noticed that
when i was in america
when i was on america
i've noticed that like they like like
the europeans and stuff like that
um but if i'm because i've been here for
so long in uk when i come back i don't
really have that my home accident you
can pick it up slightly uh but
if i start talking to you lithuanian
like if everyone i know for a fact when
i go to la point in the summer when i
come back i will have a accent because
i'll only be speaking with him so yeah i
have that too i have a german accent
like i have to try do you i don't i
honestly couldn't pick you up yeah
because i'm trying really hard like to
cover it up okay give me give me
something don't cover up let me let me
hear it okay so when i speak english i
really don't really like to do that
because oh well that the other people
would judge me for it
are you feeling german yeah nice
i finally yeah yeah
i mean yeah i mean i speak a bit of well
i speak i understand i understand
fluently russian i just can't speak it
fluently
you understand russian
russian and ukrainian because it's
similar languages
first time first time i've seen a girl
to be speaking russian like that my best
friend's russian ah she'd be teaching me
some stuff yeah of course she's like i
only choose to swear once you've got
this because it's hilarious when an
english person starts to swear
skiing oh my god some flash seeds yeah
i'm not lying to my best friend's
eastern european
you're making it really hard for me to
like you right now this actually is
actually i'm struggling right now
like what
yeah
she makes me belly manny
um do you guys like biting
don't do me do that
i don't look i don't mind it as long as
it's not like the hickey bite
yeah if it's a hickey bite i don't like
it like kiki bugs are problematic like i
got a job like
what was you doing last night like
you're like yes it's just yeah yeah you
have to wear a turtleneck for like two
weeks after that yeah like when i go
home like what
that tell next like well england's not
that warm so
maybe it will be okay but like still
like it only wearing turtlenecks the
whole time
thank you to the super chat from davon
jackson um the question is is body count
a deal breaker for either of you
and would you be honest to your partner
and tell them about it i think i'll be
honest i think to my partner i'd be
honest
because i trust this person no probably
yeah no i wouldn't have a problem
telling my partner yeah no worries
i wouldn't say it's a deal i wouldn't
take it
but i feel like
if you guys have seen the show love
island like you love island uk like i
remember hearing a guy say yeah you know
a lot of where where i work right now
it's in chicago and a lot of like the
there was a
three love island cast members that came
into the thing as well as we get a lot
of towie a lot of towie people yeah it's
actually quite quite cool cause i
yesterday i met um i don't know the
guy's name but um
i don't really watch i don't really
watch um towie like that so to be
remembering the characters names evil so
but i didn't meet one of them as well
but they have crazy body counts like one
guy said he had a 500 500 bodies but
like this wasn't lies this wasn't like
really it wasn't like so imagine
i don't think so like it's just it's
just he's just a normal essex lad
apparently 500 women oh man i don't know
if someone said that then i'm like i
don't know if i want to have a
relationship with you like that's just
that's like that would shock me like
what what sex means nothing i mean a
number to be honest a number like
obviously
at
a certain a certain like number it
obviously matters
if it's more like if for from my
perspective if a girl tells me like she
has like slept with over 200 men that's
of course of course that that's that's
some that's a big because you know what
that means that means like i'm sleeping
with a totally new guy every single
month so above 200 that's like every
single month that i began like ever
since i've started having sex i've had
sex with a new guy every single month
that means like every single guy you've
slept with you choose a new guy it's
like why would i date you because you're
just going to choose a new girl because
that's what your truck writer like your
stats are showing fair enough
yeah i think that would be a red flag
but i think normally like
i don't think it should be that
important yeah
if your celebrity crush walked in now
and asked you out would you absolutely
i'm sorry i'm sorry to say this
absolutely i'm sorry to say this but
cillian might be walking right now yeah
i kind of like tom hardy walked in there
right now
i would shake her hand exactly
and i'd be like listen
we're good to go yeah absolutely i'm
sorry
because yeah our truth is what are the
chances exactly what are the chances if
there's ever a chance absolutely yes
because that chance absolutely
fast forward yeah you're married and
you're married and that chance comes
that's a bit sticky though
yeah if i've got kids then i don't know
about that but still like
yeah
i'm thinking about it
[Laughter]
whoa all three
i mean one is okay but three no like who
would have picked that oh yeah no if you
if you had to pick yourself
all three
i was gonna do all three of them
that's mad
do we have any do you have any more um
short questions
anymore because i've been drinking this
yeah
yeah yeah you just begin to feel this oh
my cheeks
have you ever
hooked up in a public place
i think i'm going to shop for this as a
guy i don't think there's an answer to
answer this is bad i know i haven't
actually but like
i don't think even if i did i i don't
think it's just
as bad
okay hold on guys dessert
[Music]
what's for dessert we're getting like a
five-star chicken yeah that's exactly
what we're getting
i kind of love this seeing people run
around
the host with the most
[Music]
oh yeah okay i'm really excited about
this i'm very excited
you see what she's bringing to the table
you know what i'm saying you want to be
on this you want this do you want this
three-course meal email her up early
things like gmail.com
half of the people don't probably don't
even know what the auctioneer is saying
i don't think he's actually saying
anything i think it just does it for
like the flow like to keep that flow
going like 200
300 i think he's doing it for like
for him
for himself
because that's all i'm hearing like when
i watched like what was the thing in
america the um
the storage auction yeah storage
right when the guy comes in
that's what i'm hearing
i'm like what what is he saying like
what was that show like story like
storage storage or something
like imagine like you have like a
storage container and you're watching
and you're like wait that's mine
that's mine
i'm pretty sure that's what happens like
at some point they will see that like
that's there is like it was getting sold
yeah but i saw some really weird ones
like no i've seen some good ones like
when they find like lamborghini and
stuff lamborghinis
in las vegas it was a las
las vegas is vegas
i'd bet on because that because people
have money people have just like gambled
those with money so they're ready to buy
some stupid stuff
i'm gonna try this
you're gonna try to go for it i'm
excited
i can
so i got another super chat devon
jackson
um
how many countries have they had sex in
is that like a shot or shot or an answer
yeah okay i mean i have no shame
germany italy switzerland belgium
germany city
like give me a break guys
i'd say i was lithuanian
greece
um uk
and
italy what was it
yeah italy where'd you go in greece
uh kofu island was very it was a very
good idea it's arkansas
i def i would definitely recommend
anyone but go as a couple i can't ask
you the it's called the
mayo palace monastery it's a very very
nice place because it's like all the
hotel rooms are facing the ocean and
it's like rounded off it's so it's a
very beautiful place go all-inclusive a
10-day package is probably one of the
best ones you get to go on like
trips like blue lagoon and all that
stuff and that's that's a very nice i
think greece is a beautiful place so
underrated like people like yeah i'm
gonna go to bali or like go to bora bora
but like if you live in europe like why
not go to greece
there's so many islands to explore zanti
no i went to like sure where mamma mia
was filmed scotland i went there and it
was really yeah it was so beautiful
really really beautiful and the food is
amazing oh no the food is the food's
always like fresh fish frustrating i'm
sorry england england you just don't do
it for us i think it's like england
doesn't have enough sun to produce good
like fruit that tastes like stuff
like in in like in greece the food just
tastes good
it's fresh yeah it just tasted like more
like more flavor
yeah good stuff
have you ever cheated
i'm not gonna reveal that
no
if i take the drink it's obvious so i'm
just going to say
yes but not in the conventional sense
give context
okay so i was three bottles in
blacked out sleeping on a bed
okay
and then the just you know hopped on
but i had no control over so that's like
a rape though mm-hmm
yeah
then that's kind of different
but i didn't like you she was my she was
one of my like my my ex best friends
so it was a bit of a bit yeah it was a
bit it was a bit awkward because after
that we didn't really spoke like that no
more
what happened like did you nothing i
just started
[Music]
no because can you imagine if this was
the other way around like if someone
like if a guy slept like sees with a
woman that's really drunk and makes a
video about it like that's like
so like not okay but like when it's like
a guy like you're just like kind of
brushing it off like oh like we just
don't talk anymore like that i'm scared
for life like no no but that's the case
yeah
yeah
um
you're enjoying that
i love pastries
[Laughter]
have you ever committed a crime
yeah
yes what was it probably saying when i
was kids i stole some candy that's
that's slamming i think i've ever stolen
anything
it's probably like maybe a drug or
something maybe i shouldn't say that
online yeah maybe pharmaceuticals
cancelled
i took paracetamol
really what was that like i popped so
many power samples
we'll talk about this after all off off
the camera
yeah no i think i i i mean i've
i feel like like the very minimum crimes
yes like you know like littles
wanted yeah skip school i wanted to like
i wanted a candy my mom didn't buy it
for me so i just put in my pocket and
walked out happening you know just like
the small crimes like underage drinking
that's like a big thing in the uk
yeah but they don't really it's not
really like i mean yeah of course i've
like
that's why they're saying it's like oh
you're like oh you're finally
18 you can do all the things that you
was doing when you were 16 anyway you
know i mean that's it's just it's just
that
can girls and guys just be friends
um i feel like if they're not sexually
attracted to you
like i have friends that are
different sexual orientation so
they're not like the gay
and they're not history attracted to me
i feel like our friendship works
with guys i don't think
if they say they're gay if they're like
they're attracted to men they're not
attracted to oh i was actually uh
actually coming from me that would
because that's what i wanted to say but
coming i thought about it coming from me
that would have been like
red flag and i'm saying do you like the
viewers
i agree i agree i agree like most
girlfriends i've had have learned that
they're not actually friends so
yeah of course because
we're just kind of sad like imagine you
think you have a friend but really
yeah i've seen a lot of videos um of
like you know when a girl has a guy best
friend and then the guy
um tests her in that and he goes listen
caller there was a video that i told you
either call him up tell him we broke up
and then
see what basically goes and then
for from the most videos even real or
fake the responses is the same as like
oh i'll be there for you i mean like
cause he's he's basically waiting for
the guy to get moved out of the way so
he can step in and be the uh shoulder to
cry on top thing but then obviously with
more intentions behind that yeah but i'm
not even attracted to that so
any guy that have tried to be like the
friend the best friend and moved to me
that way like i'm not going to be
sexually attracted to you no like i
wouldn't make you my friend if i was
gonna be like i wanted to be sexually
attracted yeah so
fair enough
what do you think about girls and guys
being friends
i know that's why i said i agree with
you that the sexual orientation is
different then yeah then yeah do you
have any female friends
the only female friends that i have are
all in relationships with the friends
that i have that's the only but like i
only know them like that so i'd say yeah
i do
so but all of them are in our
relationships with like yeah and i'm not
close to them like that i just know them
because of my life are you sexually
attracted to any of your friends
absolutely not okay
there was a time when i was but not
anymore wait what
now there was a time of you know of
course of course
furthermore i don't know i'm joking
when i was like 17 when i didn't know
any well no sorry 17 um
16.
yeah like young i was i was young it's
like it was stupid stupidity you know my
friend had a girlfriend now she was like
very attractive so i was like oh [ __ ]
but you know i learned i learned i
learned i think it's like a maturity
thing as well i think like eventually
when you get older like you have friends
like from school and high school and
stuff like like you would just never
consider dating realistically and like
they're just going to stay like friends
and they're going to be male friends
so i'd like that you can have those kind
of friends but normally they're like
acquaintances and you don't really talk
to you that much like a real friend is
like someone that's like in your life
quite often
it's like a male friend to have or feel
my friends have that's in your life
quite regularly is difficult
if they're attractive i guess
are either of you the jealous type and
what is the most jealous thing you've
ever done
i'm really not the jettison
i wouldn't i wouldn't say that i'm a
jealous type either well i mean
it just
for a guy is a bit different because
obviously like
to define jealousy for a guy is just a
bit more complicated because like
i would say i'm not a jealous type but
obviously if a guy is hitting on my girl
and i see that obviously it's not going
to be my instinct to be like oh my god
no obviously it's going to be to come up
and you know
break his jaw but
that's but that's me but i want to say
i'm a jealous dab as far as like if
you're talking to like a person that
you're that guy i wouldn't say like i
trust you obviously and i mean it's all
about trust these days i do think i do
have the capability to be a bit jealous
but i feel like generally i'm not the
jealous type but like if someone's like
oh like i'm going to meet my ex today
like i'm going to be oh no that would
never help i'm sorry that would never
happen so in the past like one of my ex
is like oh yeah i have to meet someone
and it was like the eggs and i was like
okay i'm just not going to talk to them
today oh yeah
the silent treatment yeah because like
you know you did like
don't disrespect me no like normally i
wouldn't do it because i could really
try this thing to do but like i was just
like so shocked i was like really like
what's so important like what do you
need to talk to her about it anyway but
yeah like normally no i mean i'm good
fair enough
have you ever been offered a threesome
i'm gonna take a shot
for real
um
yeah
no comment
yeah i think we should uh have another
show actually
for the two of us
oh the third
yeah
oh my god the hypothetical thing
right now um
yeah i think next question
please thank you for the thank you for
the super chat davon jackson
okay um what is your own personal
biggest red flag
i wouldn't say this the biggest but i'd
probably i'd say lion because i was just
like
it's just not cool
i wouldn't say it's like the biggest red
flag for me but it's definitely up there
with like the two maybe top three
so what you find is under like a red
flag for somebody else and a partner
is lying or you oh you are you lying is
your red flag i don't get it no no so
like like just just
lying in general is wrong but like if if
you're looking at like if you're looking
at me like if you come back home drunk
and you know you did what you did and
you know what you did yeah
and i know like let's say i catch you
out and i know what you did so i'm just
standing there and i just i just wonder
honest truth right and then you still
look me dead in the eye and lie to me
like that that right there is just
like like go sleep by the time you wake
up your bags are packed and you're
leaving this house like yeah that's
probably that way um i think reference
for me would probably i think it's
similar to the honesty no it's like
not being true to your emotions like if
you're happy like let me know and if
you're sad let me know if you're angry
let me know because if you don't then
someone's going to be surprised when
someone like if we break up you can like
okay why because no one's showing any
emotion like you don't know like what's
going on do you think like being honest
i mean open to your emotions like
a green flag and then opposite of that
is a red flag i don't know
have you seen any red flags in the other
person on this date
i think not so far none
not yet
not yet
but i'd like to know about the threesome
though
what
what is the worst trait about yourself
as sporty as i am i love to be lazy like
if i i go out every day i work and i go
training but the last thing i want to do
is come back home and like clean and i
do it but like i just wanna no but it's
like even on a weekend right like normal
people should be like doing the washing
you know cleaning
making giving your house a tlc basically
i don't know man i like to sleep in you
know just just generally just
relax you know just like after you know
because if you've worked all week you
get that one day off a week and you just
want to relax you don't want to you know
sleep is so important like i'm reading a
book about sleep like sleep is the most
productive thing you can do does it put
you to sleep though yeah does it put you
to sleep it's an audio book so it's
still good audio book fair enough i can
fall asleep tonight
i think my most toxic trait is like um
i'm really ambitious like so ambitious
that i think it can scare other people
how ambitious we're talking elaborate on
that please like i need to know
like
i think it's one toxic straight from
like relationships is that i know i'm
good like by myself like financially
like everything that i need i have a
strong independent woman yeah like i
have everything that i want and need and
that's what's like scares people away
because
like i could out earn you or i could be
i don't know like have a success that
you might not have in like a particular
way and i feel like that scares other
people
but like i think that's my most toxic
straight like i'm really ambitious and
i'm always working on like learning
something new and if the other person
obviously doesn't
respect that then itself is gonna be
like really weird but like if you do
then it's okay like i'm not asking the
other person's like oh you need to be
academically smart you need to achieve
this or earn this amount like that
doesn't interest me this is like my own
thing yeah like some people see that
like oh i've got to meet her be
competitive with her
no it's just like this is my own mindset
that maybe might be a red flag fair
enough yeah
has an x ever dumped you and if so why
um
i'll tell you off camera
okay we got a lot of questions off
camera
um
i've broken up with people and it's been
like mutual but like i don't actually
know like why we broke up so like i
actually don't have a reason
but like
has anyone broken up with you though and
then i like personally like i'm breaking
up with you it's more like
i would they would say something that i
didn't like and then i would stop
talking to them
fair enough yeah and i kind of kind of
outlined this i'm excited
there's a lot of follow-up questions
there's a lot of what is it isn't it
yeah no i should have put a notebook
don't do it man it will be hell wow you
might need to bring two let me circle
back to i need to remember these
questions that trick
would you submit to a man
yeah
but i feel like the man has to also like
if i'm going to submit to you you need
to own the role of being like the more
dominant person in the relationship and
you need to be very decisive
i feel like you've got to have the
intelligence build the house yeah yeah
like
the intelligence and the emotion the
emotional changes and the confidence to
do that as well because if you if you
don't then i just won't because i feel
like i'm quite intelligent i'm quite
confident so you've also got to match
that or even be more than that yeah in
order for me to be like to submit to you
if that makes sense
would you be okay with being the
breadwinner and having a house husband
100 and i would also be the flip side of
that like i would love to be a housewife
and stay at home and cook and clean and
take care of my kids but i'd also like
to be the breadwinner as well and i feel
like
he said [ __ ] kids
[ __ ] them kids man
no honestly like
i don't mind that but it's like i always
always was raised like look i like
having my own money so i would like if
if if there was a chance that like we uh
we connect on this on a very deep level
and then yes you i end up being the
house i don't want to mind that oh
absolutely but cook and clean that's me
that's like work taking care of the kids
is easy yeah but it's just one of those
things where it's like i've i love
making my own money no matter how no
matter what it is i could be you know
doing my own thing yeah i just love
making my own that way there's nobody
respect that there's no there's no
there's no competition and we're like oh
i go i don't i don't need to ask my girl
oh but send me just send me that i need
to buy this and you know i mean it's
just it just makes it easier like oh i
have the money to do that myself why
would i need to ask for someone else
yeah i think it's important um for your
own confidence and your own um
independence to know that you're making
your own money like i thought it gives
you a sense of security and i think it's
like a nice thing and like taking that
away like brings kind of vulnerability
and i don't i don't think everyone
should have to go through that so like
one reason why like i'd be quite
concerned having a child with someone is
that
you're completely vulnerable and
dependable on someone else i think
that's one of the reasons why most men
don't want to be like house husbands is
because then they will be dependent on
someone else it's not an easy position
to be in and i completely respect that
you want to work because like who
doesn't want to be independent and like
self-sufficient of course yeah would you
prefer a housewife
i don't really mind to be honest like if
you know what it is
most most relationships i've seen is
like it wasn't uh like established but
it was like it just gone into that to
where like like you know the guy works
and the woman just you know no no like
just comes back home and cooks and
cleans no but like it was never like
oh we sit down and discuss it just kind
of like it happened so i've basically
from that i really don't mind like
obviously if you if we both want to work
i have no problem with you working
because at the end of the day if you're
looking from perspective of the house
needs to get paid for anyways right and
the fact that me and her are working it
just makes it a lot easier because
if we split
yeah
exactly and it's just like you save a
lot more money instead of me paying for
everything yeah i do think there's a lot
of pressure for men to be financially
responsible for everything
and that's like one of the reasons why i
think it's important like even like
personally like to be financially stable
and do your own thing because you don't
want to go into a relationship like one
person has to carry the weight of like
earning or like thinking they have to
provide for everyone i feel like
especially in today's economy like it's
really unrealistic
and it's like a lot of pressure to put
on one person that i have to go and earn
money get a promotion that kind of thing
like i wouldn't want that i would want
maybe that like i would be able to
contribute a lot and then you would be
able to contribute a lot and then you
both come to like an equal understanding
and then you both are comfortable and
you don't have to overwork yourself
to be comfortable i think that's an
important thing
would you ever date a single mother or a
single father
yeah yeah i'd say that yeah
that's and that's a little easy one
yeah i mean i really like children and i
don't understand like but like you know
from a perspective of like you know you
gotta take over the payments right like
that's that i i say yes because you know
i don't i don't really mind if there's a
connection there's a connection but like
you gotta remember you're going in with
a lot like taking care of the kid plus
the payments and all that stuff so i
guess it's like a financial issue but
like also like a personal issue like
obviously taking care of a child that
isn't like biologically yours like would
you be comfortable with that and i feel
like i would be comfortable with that
like i really do enjoy like spending
time with children i grew up in a big
family and i love having children around
so it wouldn't really bother me but i
guess it's also like we've got to deal
with the past relationship that comes
with that i guess that could be a bit
problematic if they've got like a
ex-wife or ex-girlfriend i think that
brings a lot of drama i don't know if
i'm ready for that
drama is in here tonight anyways
they want you to do a thumb war
a thumb war
should we do an arm wrestle this morning
you know like i look bad if i if i if i
win so you know he's one of those ones
but i'm very competitive so
go on yeah i'm a bit drunk
no more somewhere
don't break my nails please one
oh
i saw you at the gym i was like oh she's
pretty strong i'm sorry yeah yeah i'm in
the gym quite often i'm not going to lie
to you
yeah something i need to do more of i
just run a lot
the basket was just like a lot of cardio
just in general
i do too much cardio i need to like stop
pulling weights like my desired body
type oh what is your desired body type i
know a bit more like thicker you know oh
a little in the middle but she got much
back yeah
[Applause]
okay yeah
so i think i do too much cardio but like
i feel like i have like something a
skillet like i don't know like lots of
people don't like cardio and i really
enjoy it that's the problem like i have
something that other people don't enjoy
like i shouldn't even be doing it
because i should be like doing weights
and stuff yeah fair enough yeah
how would you rate this date one to ten
and the service the service is 110
percent
20. yeah like great pearl's doing a
great job like we got dessert too you
know
thank you
yeah i'm having fun this year i'm having
that i definitely haven't this is
definitely like something that
unorthodox is not something that i've
done before so this is
yeah and like before you guys are like
i've only met dobby dust like one time
before so like yeah this is yeah this is
quite interesting it's very interesting
because you wouldn't normally talk about
this kind of stuff on like a first or
even the second day no
which is which which is what makes it
like great because it's obviously just
like it's unexpected content you know i
mean it's like i would have never liked
yeah i'm really interested i have so
many more questions for you now
let's know it
like follow a question follow up
questions
guys just so you know in the chat they
literally like i had this idea today
and we just like did this on the spot so
they both were really good sports about
it oh
thanks i think we met like two days ago
was it two days ago
like the day before yesterday yeah it
was yesterday no it wasn't yet sunday
night or sunday saturday or saturday
saturday yeah yeah
it's like that's not a long time
i feel like i get an american accent
listen to listening to pearl
when i speak to a lot of the americans i
just yeah because i i adapt my accent so
like if i talk to people enough like i
feel like after a while like i'm gonna
have an american accent so if you guys
watch this like oh this girl's accents
like fine thanks
hey guys how are you doing
what are you talking about that was like
australian oh my god oh my god oh my oh
my god
oh my god
omg live
yesterday
i think i could do like a really good
value accent vallejo
like california yeah but kelly williams
fair enough one like
have a go
oh my god so like i was in like
starbucks yesterday
and he spelled my name wrong
i feel like that's like i said i have
the sound oh hell no dog i know you did
not back down from that i know you gave
it something
you do like a southern accent i can the
thing is i can adapt to the axes really
easily that's what makes you like i feel
like i could do the tech snacks in a
little bit
oh that was the best time you think so i
don't think so i don't know
i'm gonna need to i'm gonna need my text
and friends to validate you real quick
i found a friend option phone a friend
yeah i think i can do like an australian
accent really well good day mate
you wanna go first put a shrimp on the
barbie put the shrimp on the barbie do
you wanna go first
let's go in the water now let's go
let's go
no i'm pretty good it's been fun
okay crazy card you guys get to pick a
question for each other
a question for each other yes
i don't know
hmm okay if you had to travel anywhere
in the world where would you go like
right now oh we're talking like okay i
was gonna go so much more so much more
in like deeper okay lynn you go first
have you got any fetishes
um i got to know
i don't know if you should do this on
camera i don't i don't i i don't
honestly i don't have anything i don't
think anything that's like oh like this
will change the game for you like i
don't think there's anything that would
like change a scenario completely on its
head because you do it okay so i don't
think it would be like so strong enough
to say fetish but i'd say like maybe a
strong like
okay yeah i still know you're answering
my question
yeah that's true yeah you know i'm
saying that's cool to open up and tell
me about yours i don't have any that's
something that actually honestly i don't
have any okay so it's not something like
one girlfriend like you can be having an
okay time and this one girl does this
and it'll be like okay
just switched it all up
no honestly i don't actually no not
really
i actually don't have any pages that's
funny i thought you saw that interesting
question to ask
what's your question what was it what
what kind of okay like where would you
travel if like money unlimited any
anywhere
probably just a little bit off
everywhere like if if i had like a
limited money i'll probably travel the
world man but like one place you can go
oh one place oh um
um
i'll probably say bora bora on bora boy
that sounds nice i think my sister's
going on on the little
rings out there so i'll be like scuba
diving looking for that like
she lost it i found it yeah that's cloud
if you if you find that ring find that
right oh my lord you're you're texting
child kylie jenner everyone's up after
that when i find this ring like
everyone's good like everyone's good for
life now you school challenge darling i
found your ring yeah i'm paying it
forward like i
yeah fair enough yeah
would you marry someone who was a corn
star or
off
no
no that's personal preference i know
people that would but yeah of course but
for the clout i think that's like him i
think their intentions are different
because
why would you want that yeah no i i
wouldn't i wouldn't and you never know
like when that phrase is gonna reoccur
so that it could be like like 40 and
like yeah like i'm gonna start doing
only fans of corn again and then you're
gonna be like okay then
what'd you do like support it
yeah like i i don't want that
complicated never okay that's too
complex for me
okay
and i think i'm gonna close out last
question okay
actually two questions okay one is there
going to be a second date
i think so
i had fun
wait on live oh
justin
[Laughter]
and uh second question is he gonna get
lucky tonight oh
what
i don't think so
i'm pretty i'm pretty drunk yeah i'm
gone and i've got work tomorrow yeah
i've got work tomorrow as well date
three day three
we haven't planned we haven't got them
you're talking too much into the future
putting us on the spot that's what i do
i know yeah it's just paul's job this
pel's job yeah exactly she's doing her
job i i rate that okay guys thank you so
much for doing this live this was so fun
very interesting experience
i've never done this before
highly recommend yeah 100 okay guys let
me know if you're in london and you want
to be set up on a blind date maybe we
can make this a weekly thing
my service is impeccable right
yeah
yes
very much so
okay guys tell them to subscribe to the
channel
and turn on the notification button
and paula's excellent service so you
want that three-course meal i know
everybody who i don't know
who would turn down free drinks and free
course meals come on can you see how to
surprise the drinks
do you want water oh it's asking so
hospitable
she's already southern she's like
midwest like chicago but still like
hospitals
yeah
torso you're saying me don't you have a
boyfriend now
someone in the chat said me i'm like i
swear to god i thought you had a
boyfriend
no should we on a date with paul that's
and that would be interesting
but yeah we've got to sit we gotta we go
we're gonna find out though
i feel like they should be like mobile
guys but like she could like
[Music]
what do you mean wait wait explain more
this idea so we get a bunch of guys for
you right
and like you asked some questions and
then like you would like okay like no
yeah so like they'll give you a pick-up
line and you'd
swipe yes or no
yes do you go into like little speakers
where are you going to find these guys
oh don't worry we will go
guys the best
i'm pretty sure your favorite donuts i
would not mind doing a date with you
oh my favorite sentient sentience where
are you at i miss you
i missed you in the street london's a
big city
there's enough supply
yeah the right ones it's just demand
that's gone possibly all right let me
know in the comments if you guys want to
see that next week let me know this is
something that like you know we're kind
of testing out on the channel different
show i